All right, good morning.
Can people hear me in the Zoom meeting?
I'm not going to start until somebody
responds affirmatively.
Hooray.
All right.
So, I realized that it's been a minute
since I went over the answers to the
quiz questions from the last few
quizzes.
So, let's take a moment to do that
before we we jump into the rest of
today.
So,
here's some older quizzes.
So, quiz number eight, this was this was
from like a week and a half ago.
So, this was this was Chandy Lamport.
So, consider a distributed system with
two processes, P1 and P2.
Suppose that P1 initiates the snapshot
algorithm. What does P1 do after
recording its own state? The answer that
we were looking for here was just
it sends marker messages.
So, it does some other stuff after that,
but the important thing is that it must
send the marker messages right after
recording its own state. And that's to
make sure that no other events happen in
between it recording its own state and
it sending the marker messages out
because if it if they did, then that
could lead to problems in the recorded
snapshot. So, that's the answer we were
looking for there. Send out marker
messages.
That was quiz number eight.
Quiz number nine. What does it mean for
an algorithm to be decentralized? So,
the way that we defined it in class was
we said a decentralized algorithm is
just one that can have multiple
initiators. So, Chandy Lamport was our
first example of a decentralized
algorithm.
Some people define this differently and
I actually got some different good
responses to this one.
So, my colleague Owen Arden, for
example, uh
defines decentralization as um as having
to do with trust and having to do with
the participants not trusting one
another. So, that's an aspect of
decentralization, and that's how it
might be defined in some communities. Um
but for the purposes of this class, uh
uh we are just saying decentralization
means there can be more than one
initiator, and we'll we'll see that
again uh later on when we talk about
Paxos.
Uh quiz 10. Uh which of these are
liveness properties? Um
Somebody just shout out the answer to
this one. Which if any of these is a
liveness property?
So, the options are reliable delivery,
FIFO delivery, causal delivery, total or
to- totally ordered delivery. Yeah, so
the only one of these that's a liveness
property is reliable delivery. The rest
of them are safety properties. So, that
means they're properties that can
uh be violated in a finite execution,
which means that we can write down uh
on a piece of paper easily a violation
of them.
Uh reliable delivery doesn't have that
property. So, that one is a liveness
property.
Quiz 11.
All right. So,
suppose you have a key-value store that
clients access by sending messages, and
the question is what would be an example
of an item potent from a client, and
what would be an example of a non-item
potent message? So, recall that an item
potent message is one where it's okay uh
if the message is delivered and takes
effect uh more than once.
Uh so, in this case, uh so the example
that we talked about in class, we said
that uh assigning a value to a variable,
or in this case assigning a value to a
key, uh would be item potent. Uh
and is assuming that there are no other
messages interleaved with those item
potent messages. Uh, but an example of a
non-item potent message would be an
increment operation because if that
increment was only supposed to happen
once and instead it happened twice, uh,
then you would be in trouble.
Um,
so that's what we were going for there.
I think we're caught up now on on quiz
responses, um,
and uh, we'll have another quiz today.
All right. On to today's topic.
So last time we began to talk about, uh,
uh,
at the very end of last time we began to
talk about replication and we kind of
got into this topic of replication, uh,
by a by observing that
it's often the case that we mitigate,
uh,
loss of something by making copies,
right? So we mitigate message loss by
making copies of messages and likewise,
uh, we replicate or we mitigate loss of
state by making copies of state. So
making copies of state, making copies of
data, uh, in other words, replication.
Uh, so just to review what we talked
about at the very ends of very end of
last time,
uh,
if we have a process and the process has
some events on it.
So this, uh,
goes back to what we talked about at the
beginning of the class where we can
think of each of those events as being a
state, uh, and whatever our state is at
a certain point is determined by all the
events, uh, that took place up until
then. Uh, and maybe we also have some,
uh, memory.
Some process local memory, like maybe
this process knows that X is five. Um,
and we can replicate this thing.
Along with the state.
And so, why would we do this? Well, the
most important reason to do it is, well,
now if one of these processes crashes,
now we still that fact that X is five
isn't lost forever. So, that's one
reason to do replication.
Uh
mitigating data loss. So, we can just
write down some reasons to do
replication.
And as we talked about at the end of
last time, uh there are other important
reasons to do replication. And so, one
of the reasons that that that was
mentioned was
uh
was scalability.
So,
there's different aspects to this to
what I mean by scalability, but one
thing I mean is dividing up the work,
right? So, if you're getting a lot of
messages, if you're getting a lot of
requests for the value of X, and you're
having a hard time handling it all, it
might make sense to have another machine
to take some of the burden off of you.
Uh and this is especially relevant if
the requests are coming uh from
different physical locations, and you
would like these replicas to be close to
those physical locations uh so that you
can serve them more quickly. So, it's
likely that a a machine that's
physically closer for to you is going to
be able to respond faster. Um so, data
locality
is a reason to do replication. You want
the copies to be close to you.
Um
and so, that's that's something else
that we get in addition to this. So, I'm
going to put fault tolerance here.
Uh
and then
scalability.
So, these are all reasons to do
replication.
Uh what we didn't really get to talk
about at the end of last time is what
are the downsides of replication?
So,
even though replication has all these
advantages, you really don't want to do
it unless you need to.
So, so why is that? What are What are
the reasons not to do replication?
Yeah.
You need to maintain consistency.
So,
having to keep replicas consistent is a
huge problem.
And this can be very complicated, uh
especially if they can crash, right?
Which was the whole reason why we wanted
to do replication in the first place, or
one of the reasons.
And it's also especially hard if they're
physically far apart, uh which was
another reason why we wanted to do
replication.
And it's also hard to do if they're both
serving requests, which was another
reason why we wanted to do replication.
Uh so, all of the things that make
replication important and necessary
uh also make it hard to do.
And another reason not to do it is just
that it's expensive, right?
So,
you have to buy more machines, right? Or
you have to rent them from Amazon or
Google uh or Microsoft or some other
cloud computing service, right? And you
have to do it in advance if you want to
protect your data, right? It's not like
with message loss, where if you lose a
message, if a message is lost, you just
send it again. Uh with data loss, if a
machine fails, then you better have
already had a replica up and running.
You can't just go buy another machine
after the first one fails, because by
then it's too late. So, you need to make
this upfront investment in order to
protect your data.
And that does indeed end up being
expensive.
Um so,
yeah. So, having to keep replicas
consistent, this can be very
complicated. And we're going to talk
about protocols for doing replication
that try to address this.
So, um
let's go back to our favorite picture of
a total order anomaly.
So, this picture uh
illustrates one of the challenges with
replication.
So, the issue here
is that different events
happened in different orders
on two replicas.
So, on replica one,
X gets assigned to one and then to five.
On replica two, X gets assigned to five,
and then to one. And the problem is that
these two replicas then end up being
inconsistent.
Um but I want to talk about one thing
here to to make clear what it is uh that
we want to get out of our replicated
systems. So, imagine for a second uh
what it would look like if we had only
one replica.
Uh so, let's just call it R
instead of R1 and R2. So, imagine we
still have the two clients,
but we just have one replica R.
So,
clients are still sending the messages.
So, it could happen like this.
Right?
Or it could happen like this.
So, if this first situation happens,
then we end up with X being two.
If the second one happens, then we end
up with X being one.
So, even with one replica,
um which probably shouldn't even be
called a replica in this context because
there's only one of it, um it's possible
that these messages are going to arrive
in different orders on different runs.
And there's not an obviously
better choice, right, out of these two
runs.
Right? Like I can't look at them and say
that one is correct and the other isn't.
But neither of these pictures shows a
total order anomaly, right? Because
recall the definition of totally ordered
delivery. We said, if a process delivers
message one and then message two, then
all processes delivering both message
one and message two deliver message one
first.
So there's no totally ordered delivery
violation in either of these pictures,
uh because there is only one process.
And so whatever happens on that process
just is correct. So notice that process
R has a lot of control here over when to
deliver messages, right? R establishes
the total order by deciding when to
deliver each message that it gets.
Now it could establish a different order
from one run to the next, but doing so
has nothing to do with the totally
ordered delivery property.
So
having the order be the same from one
run to the next would be a different
property.
Uh and that property is called
determinism.
So
determinism is a property that relates
multiple runs of a system to each other.
So this
when that run does this and this other
run does this,
this is a violation of determinism. It's
not a violation of totally ordered
delivery.
And this is important to point out
because even though totally ordered
delivery is a nice property to have,
it's important to be aware that it still
doesn't give you determinism.
So, the totally ordered delivery
property is a property uh that can only
be true or not true of a single run.
Uh so, determinism
is a property that relates multiple
runs. So, you can't look at a single run
and say, "Is the system deterministic?"
You have to be looking at multiple runs.
Uh by the way, um a property that
relates multiple runs to each other uh
is called a hyper property.
So, determinism is an example of a hyper
property.
Um this is not actually important to the
class. I just think hyper property is a
fun word to say.
All right. So,
back to talking about
totally ordered delivery.
So, when there's only one replica,
notice that it establishes a total order
on a given run.
What we would like to do is make it so
that there can be multiple replicas, but
keep this nice totally ordered property.
Uh in other words, we want clients to
think that they're only dealing with one
replica. We want them to think that
they're dealing with a system that does
not have multiple replicas.
Uh so, here's an informal definition of
what we want.
We'll say
a replicated storage system
is strongly consistent
if clients
can't tell
that it is replicated.
So, we want it to appear to clients
as though there's only one replica,
even though under the hood we may have
many.
So, it turns out that every strongly
consistent replication protocol that
we're going to discuss is going to work
by establishing a total order on events,
but they're all going to do it in
different ways.
Uh so, the first one we're going to talk
about uh
is called uh is and well, before we do
that, let's let's before we get into
particular approaches for establishing
this total order and and and
implementing strong consistency, let's
first talk about some of the ways where
a client might be able to tell that data
has been replicated. Or in other words,
uh different ways in which replicas
might disagree.
So, okay. So, one of the most obvious
bad things that can happen
um would be something like this.
So, let's say you have a client
and you have two replicas.
So, when the client does a write,
X is five,
and then the client tries to do a read,
but they're reading the other replica.
And then,
who knows what'll happen.
So, if our client writes to R1 that X is
five, for instance, and then she tries
to read X, and the read goes to some
other replica that didn't know about X
or didn't know about that update,
um then that might seem odd to our
client, right?
Um so, this property that the property
that's being violated here is called
read your writes.
So, this is called a read your writes
violation,
or read your writes anomaly. It's one of
the most fundamental things you should
ask of any distributed storage system.
But, some systems still don't provide
it.
Um okay.
Here's another thing that could go
wrong.
Suppose we have a
this time,
two clients,
and two replicas.
And let's say we have a a replicated
bank account.
So, in the previous example,
uh
R1 got an update. It got that update of
of X equals five, and it never bothered
to tell R2 about it.
Um but, what if R1 did tell R2 about
updates, but in the wrong order.
So, imagine if it's something like this.
So,
if it's a bank account, and maybe client
one um deposits $50.
And let's say R1 sends an
acknowledgement.
So, we know that deposit went through.
And then let's say that client two tries
to do a withdrawal.
So, if they get the acknowledgement that
happened, then the withdrawal should be
safe, right? So, it should be safe to
withdraw, say, $40 at this point.
Um well, let's say that this happens.
Um
so,
maybe they even get a response here that
says, "Okay."
But then this replica
passes this information on to replica
two,
but does so
in the wrong order.
So, now replica two over here, assuming
it started with zero,
right? At this point right here, it's
now overdrawn.
So,
if client two, maybe client two is Maybe
it's even the same person, but they're
looking at their account from uh from
their phone instead of their laptop. At
this point, if they try to look at their
balance,
uh
then the response is going to be sad,
right?
So,
in addition to just being a different
device used by the same person, uh maybe
this client two over here is actually
some automated process that the bank
runs, right? That
that periodically checks to see if
people are overdrawn.
Um
So, the deposit and the withdrawal are
getting flipped around here at replica
two.
Now, the fact that this client waited
for this acknowledgement before doing
the withdrawal, um means that
she should be able to have some
confidence, right? That her withdrawal
happens after the deposit. Um so, she
has that in her communication with
replica one, but maybe the replicas
aren't so conscientious in their
communication with each other.
So, if the deposit and the withdrawal
got flipped around here, and another
client happens to do this read, um then
that client will see that the account is
overdrawn. Um by the way, banks
sometimes do try to reorder transactions
in a way that's beneficial to them.
Uh Wells For- Wells Fargo got in trouble
for it uh for manipulating transaction
order to maximize overdraft fees.
Um
So, So, anyway,
what kind of an anomaly that we've seen
before does this look like?
Yeah, so it looks to me like it's a FIFO
anomaly, right?
So, here's our picture of a FIFO anomaly
that we saw before. So, there seems to
be
a a violation of FIFO
between replica one and replica the
here.
Um so, this is what we would call
a violation of FIFO consistency.
So, when we're talking about replica
consistency,
um,
uh, we can define FIFO consistency. Uh,
so, before we talked about uh, read your
writes. Um, so, read your writes
consistency is is um, is somewhat
self-explanatory. Um, but we can define
FIFO consistency this way.
We'll say,
writes done
by a single process
are seen by all
processes in the order they were issued.
By the way, um,
in this example, it could have uh,
it could have just been one client as
well.
Um,
in that case, we would still have a
violation of of FIFO consistency, even
if this client over here hadn't made
this observation. Uh, but the
observation over here, uh,
is uh,
kind of illustrates why it's bad to have
a violation of FIFO consistency.
Okay.
Here's another bad thing that could
happen.
Let's stick with our bank example.
Let's say that client one makes a
deposit
of $100
and gets an ack.
Um
let's say client two comes along.
Um client two comes along, checks the
balance.
Um and sees that there's
$100 in the account.
Okay. So, client two then tries to do a
withdrawal.
And they can't.
Uh somebody asked to see the violation
or to see the definition of of FIFO
consistency again. So, here's the
definition of FIFO consistency.
Okay.
So, back here.
So, client two comes along, checks the
balance, sees that the balance was a
hundred,
then tries to do withdrawal.
Unfortunately, that withdrawal hits the
other replica. So, if we said that these
started at zero,
um then they would try to do their
withdrawal and get sad face,
insufficient funds.
So, why did client two think that they
could do a withdrawal? Well,
the withdrawal is being done because of
this earlier deposit.
And client two found out about this
earlier deposit, right? Because they did
this balance uh inquiry here.
So, if you follow the chain of events,
um you can see that this deposit of a
hundred dollars
happened before the withdrawal in the
sense of happened before that we've
talked about. We can walk down this
chain of events here and see that this
happened before this, happened before
this, happened before this, happened
before this, happened before the
withdrawal.
So, you can see that the deposit of a
hundred dollars happened before the
withdrawal. And so, client two isn't
doing anything wrong.
The problem is that replica two sees the
withdrawal, but it doesn't see this
thing that's in the causal history of
the withdrawal.
So, in particular,
replica two doesn't see the deposit.
So, because
replica two sees this, but doesn't see
everything that's in its causal history,
this is a violation of what we can call
causal consistency.
Okay, so somebody's asking, okay, why
did client two uh why did client two
read from replica two instead of replica
one? Um yeah, so so good question. Yeah,
so in a replicated storage system, you
might not have control over which
replica you're talking to, right? Now,
what we'll see in a minute when we start
to look at some protocols for
replication, uh is that clients are
sometimes forced to interact with a
particular replica, and that's in fact
how consistency is enforced. Um but
yeah, the the
you could argue that the issue in this
case was that the client talked to
replica two, and if only all clients
talked to replica one, we would have no
problems. But also, if all clients only
talked to replica one, then we lose out
on a lot of the benefits of replication.
So, that's why.
Okay, so we can define causal
consistency, and I'll put it on the same
page as FIFO here.
We'll say
writes that
are
potentially causally related
In other words, related by happens
before.
Must be seen
by all processes
in the same order.
So,
we've talked about several different
consistency guarantees. I talked about
read your rights, uh I talked about
FIFO, I talked about causal,
and then I talked about informally at
least I talked about strong consistency
and we said our informal definition of
strong consistency was that clients
couldn't tell that the data was
replicated at all.
So we can put these different
consistency guarantees in a hierarchy.
Um
So
read your rights consistency
is near the bottom of the hierarchy.
FIFO consistency is a step up from that.
Causal consistency is a step up from
that.
Strong consistency is a step up from
And there are more that I could add to
this picture. Many more in fact.
There was a paper that came out a few
years ago which discussed over 50
different notions of consistency. I
promise not to make you learn about all
of them.
But I'm bringing this up because I want
to emphasize that different systems make
different consistency choices and higher
up
isn't necessarily better. There are good
reasons to want to pick something weaker
than strong consistency. So we'll come
back to that later in the course. Right
now though we're going to talk about
replication strategies that enforce
strong consistency
which we informally defined as meaning
clients can't tell that the data is
replicated.
So we're going to talk about a couple of
replication strategies both of which
enforce strong consistency.
Um
And so let's uh
Let's jump into that.
Uh there was a request to see the
definition of causal consistency again.
Here you go.
Okay.
Actually, you know what? Um I think now
is a good time to do a quiz question.
So, let's do that.
So, here is today's quiz question.
And I will share it.
Form should be accepting responses now.
Ah, so there's some
good questions uh
on Twitch. So, uh
somebody asks about uh um relationship
to serializability uh in database
theory. Um yeah, so this is a great
question. Um so,
it's not exactly the same thing. Um so,
when we talk about uh when we talk about
strong consistency,
uh we're not going to um
necessarily define this any more
formally than the way that I defined it
uh which was to say um
uh
we say that replicas are strongly
consistent if clients can't tell that
the data is replicated. Uh but um the
the gold standard definition uh for
strong consistency is is something
called linearizability uh which was uh
defined by Maurice Herlihy and Jeannette
Wing in the '90s. Um linearizability is
not the same thing as serializability.
Uh
Peter Bailis actually has a nice blog
post about this. So, if you just Google
for linearizability and serializability,
you should be able to find his post. Um
but um yeah, so serializability um
uh
is a is a different notion. Um and it
has to do with um
uh if I can remember correctly. Um it
uh ability to reorder transactions. So,
um we're not talking about transactions
in this case. We're talking about single
operations.
Uh
there are notions of consistency that do
have to do uh uh with transactions. Um
but we're mostly concerned with
non-transactional notions of
consistency. So, all of these
transactional um or all of these all of
these notions of consistency that I've
talked about, so FIFO consistency,
causal consistency,
uh read-your-writes consistency, uh
these are all considered
non-transactional.
All right, we'll wait a minute longer
here.
All right.
Let's move on.
So, we're going to start talking about
uh ways to enforce strong consistency.
Uh replication strategies that enforce
strong consistency. The first one we're
going to talk about is called primary
backup replication.
So, the idea is pretty straightforward.
We pick a particular replica to be
what's called the primary
and the other replicas are backups.
So, let's call the primary P
and let's say that we have two backups,
B1 and B2.
And the idea is that, as some of you
might have had have anticipated,
clients only interact with the primary.
So, when the primary gets a write from a
client,
it then broadcasts that write to all the
backups.
And they all send an act to the primary.
At the point when all of the backups
have acknowledged the write to the
primary, then the primary can tell the
client that the write succeeded.
And this point right here, this point at
which all of the backups have
acknowledged the primary,
we call this the commit point.
So, this is the point at which the write
uh can officially have been said to
happen.
And at that point, the primary is
actually allowed to deliver the write to
itself.
Uh and then we can act the client.
So that's how write writes work. What
about reads? Uh what is the client do
when it wants to read the value of X?
Anyone know?
Or want to take a guess?
Sure, okay. Yeah, so if the client
somebody says is does the read happen
after the commit point? Well, yeah, so
the client doesn't know exactly when
this commit mark point is, but if the
client tries to read a value that it
just wrote before it got the
acknowledgement, then all bets are off,
right?
So if you're the client and you do a
write and you haven't gotten an ack of
that right yet, then you should have no
expectation of that right actually
having taken effect. So if the client
does the does a read up here somewhere
before it does before it gets the ack,
then who knows what'll happen.
Um but let's assume that the client is
is doing the read sometime after it's
gotten the ack. Um who does it do the
read to?
It just talks to the primary.
So we can extend these lines a little
bit here.
Um
So it just asks the primary.
So there's no need for reads to be
broadcast to the other replicas, and
then the primary responds.
Or in this case I guess it would
actually return the value five.
So, if the client tries to read X while
this whole broadcast and ack process is
still happening over here, then it
indeed it might get an old value of X,
but that's okay because it's uh
it it's right wasn't acknowledged yet.
So, it should have no expectation of
having
uh
the right having actually taken effect.
So, that's primary backup. Um
it's pretty simple. Writes get broadcast
to backups. Backups have to ack the
primary before the primary ack the
client.
And reads just get answered by the
primary. This is all a very old idea.
It's been around since the '70s at
least.
Um what are the drawbacks to this?
Yeah, okay.
So, yeah, so one drawback, right, is
that it's slow.
The primary is a bottleneck. Remember
how we said that one of the reasons to
do replication is to spread the work
around, right? So, we listed several
reasons for doing replication. Um so,
fault tolerance was the number one
reason. Um and then we said data
locality. Um and then we said dividing
up the work. Um
Uh so, does primary backup replication
help with any of those things?
So,
dividing up the work that uh we could
also we could also call that um
horizontal scaling.
Okay. So, does primary backup
replication help with any of these
things? Does it help with fault
tolerance?
Hmm, some people are saying no. I would
argue that it does help with fault
tolerance, right? Because if the issue
here is that a replica could crash,
right? If the primary crashes, then one
of these backups could take over.
Um
and we know that the backups are not
going to be behind, right? Because
commits uh or writes don't commit on the
primary until they've already happened
and been acknowledged by the backups.
So, you know that the backups are going
to be at least as up-to-date as the
primary. Um so, primary backup
replication does actually help uh with
fault tolerance.
Does it help at all with data locality,
though?
No, it doesn't.
Because everybody's just talking to the
primary. That's right. So, it doesn't
help with that. The primary has to
handle all the writes and reads.
So, we can't have a replica that's
particularly close to some clients.
So, it doesn't help with that.
And it doesn't help with dividing up the
work, either.
Everybody has to talk to the primary.
So, it helps with fault tolerance, so
that's something. That's great.
Um
but uh
it doesn't help with these other things
that were other reasons for doing
replication.
Okay.
Somebody asked in chat uh
which backup takes over uh when the
primary dies. Well, it doesn't really
matter, right? Because
if the primary dies, then
all you really want is for all of the
rights that have been committed on the
primary uh to have not been lost, right?
So, any of these backups would do,
right? Because we can't commit on the
primary until all of the backups have
acknowledged the right.
Uh so, it doesn't really matter which
one takes over. Um if there is some
ordering of them, then we could just
say, "Okay, whoever's next in line." Uh
maybe if you had a if you had some more
sophisticated way of knowing which one
is less likely to fail, uh then maybe
you would choose that one to be the
primary.
Uh but um
there's no uh the in the definition of
primary backup uh
that we're laying out here, um
it's not that important uh which backup
takes over for the primary if somebody
does have to take over.
Okay, so a natural question to ask at
this point is, "Could we do better?"
Um could we spread out the work any
better? Could we make it so that the
primary doesn't have to do all the work?
Does anybody have any suggestions on how
to do that?
So, one suggestion in chat is uh allow
the client to talk to any server. Um so,
you all are kind of uh
jumping ahead. Uh this is something that
we're going to talk about later. Um
so, the the advantage of having the
client just talk to the primary, right?
Is that
that that challenge that we had earlier
of of trying to establish a total order
of events
uh that we saw here.
Um
So,
that challenge is being met by having
the primary be in charge of the order of
events. So, in other words, it's like
these scenarios where the clients are
talking to the single replica, and then
that replica has some other um processes
back here
that only the replica uh or or only the
primary talks to.
So,
clients never interact with those
backups.
Um so, the primary ends up being in
charge of the order of events.
And if you allowed clients to talk to
any replica, then knowing the order of
events suddenly gets a lot harder.
Um
But, of course, then we have the problem
of the of the primary being a
bottleneck. So, is there any way that we
could make a small change to the way
that this is happening here
uh that would help maybe spread out the
work a little more?
Yeah, so one suggestion already in chat
is a good one. So, it says, "Have the
backups take care of reads."
So, instead of having reads go to the
client, have the reads go over here. So,
if we do that,
uh we could do that, right? But, we
wouldn't necessarily know what we'd be
reading, right? We might actually be
reading data from the future, right?
Because
if you if you do a a read over here to
this backup,
um
you that backup might have data that's
actually more up-to-date than what's on
the primary. Cuz when we read from the
primary, we know
uh when a previous rate has finished,
right? Because it acknowledges us.
But with the backups, who knows what
state they're in, right?
Well, okay. So, we could try picking out
a particular backup to always read it
from
and then have that backup acknowledge us
when the rights to the primary have
finished.
So, let's try that.
So, we have our client.
Okay,
and we say when we do a write
we send it here just like we did before.
But what we want to do is we want to
allow one of the backups to handle
reads.
Let's say that we're going to have the
last backup handle reads.
So, what we'll do is we'll have the
primary pass along the right
to backup one here.
Backup one passes it along to backup
two.
And backup two acknowledges the client.
And then if the client wants to do a
read
they can do it from here.
We just invented chain replication.
So, this is uh
this is actually a fairly new idea
compared to primary backup replication.
Um the paper came out in 2004.
And it's called chain replication
for supporting
high throughput
and availability
by uh
Van Renesse and Schneider.
So, we really should be picking
different names for these things, right?
Because now that we don't have uh we
don't have a single node that's handling
all rights and reads, I don't want to
call it primary anymore. Uh and in fact,
that's not what the chain replication
people call it. Um they call this
process the head process, so I'll call
it H for head.
Um and they call this process here the
tail.
So, I'll call that one T for tail.
And then this one
it doesn't really have a name. We'll
just call it B for backup.
So, in chain replication um there could
be any number of replicas.
Um, but we always have one that's the
head and one that's the tail.
Um, so we have one node that just
handles writes, and that's the head.
And we have one that just handles reads,
and that's the tail.
And then any number that's in between.
And when we do a write, we send it to
the head node.
We pass it along to the next node in the
chain. That one passes it along to the
next node, and so on until we're at the
tail. The tail then acknowledges the
client.
So, we've managed to divide up the work
a little better than we did before,
right? We divided up the work at least
into writes and reads now.
Okay, so somebody's asking, it's a good
question, how does this allow high
throughput, right? They claim they make
this claim, right? High throughput in
the title of the paper.
Bold claim.
Okay.
So, what do you think they mean by high
throughput? What is throughput?
We'll define it as number of actions
per unit of time.
So,
if we have a more or less equal mix of
writes and reads,
then in theory, chain replication is
going to be a better choice than primary
backup replication because since we have
one node handling writes and one
handling reads, then we can process more
requests in a given amount of time of
time, at least in theory.
Um, so depending on the mix of writes
and reads, chain replication might beat
primary backup replication in in of
throughput.
What's the downside of chain
replication?
Here's the picture again.
Yeah. So,
with primary backup,
when the client did a write,
how long did they have to wait before
getting an ack? Let's look at the
primary backup picture again here.
So, when the client does a write,
the primary broadcasts this message out
to all of the backups.
Those backups acknowledge the client,
and there could be any number of
backups, by the way. Um so, there could
be three,
in which case this would go out to all
of them.
And so on. There could be any number of
backups.
Uh
So,
the primary has to wait to get all those
acknowledgements, but all of those
broadcast messages go out in parallel,
right?
Um
so,
it still might be slow to have to wait
for all the acknowledgements, but it
scales nicely. If we add more backups,
um there's still the same amount of
waiting to do on average, right?
So,
the the the longest thing that we have
to wait for is whichever one of these
backups is slowest to respond to the
primary. So, there's going to be four
messages, right? There's the time it
takes for this message to get to the
primary, there's the time that it takes
for the slowest one of these to get to
one of the backups, and the then there's
the time it takes for the slowest one of
the acks to get back to the primary, and
then there's this response here.
Um so, it's four messages.
And if we added more backups, that
number would still be four, um because
the primary contacts every backup in
parallel. So, it's a constant number
four.
Constants are great.
But, how long does it take to get an
acknowledgement of a write when you're
doing chain replication?
Well,
here we had three. We had the head, the
middle one, and the tail.
So, this took one message, this took one
message, this took one message, and this
took one message. So, here it's four.
But, if I made this chain longer,
then that number would also get bigger,
right? So, it depends on the length of
the chain.
Yeah.
So,
chain replication has worse write
latency.
So, we'll define latency
as
time between
invocation
and completion
of a single action.
What about read latency?
Is that going to be any different for
primary backup and chain replication?
So, here's what it looks like for chain
replication.
Reads go to the tail.
The tail responds to the client.
For primary backup,
reads go to the primary, and then the
primary responds to the client. Is that
going to be any different in terms of
latency?
It shouldn't be, right? That just takes
two messages in either case.
Okay.
So, chain replication
could give us better throughput
in certain cases, depending on the mix
of writes and reads in your application.
Um but it's worse in terms of in terms
of write latency,
depending on the number of uh
of
uh nodes that there are in the chain.
Um in terms of read latency, it's the
same either way.
Okay.
So,
chain replication, primary backup
replication,
uh
have different advantages and
disadvantages.
Um
and they're both pretty commonly used.
So, um
one reason to
want to do chain replication, right? Uh
is this throughput argument.
Um but one thing that you have to keep
in mind there is that writes and reads
uh don't take the same amount of time.
So, writes are more expensive than
reads. So, if you have, let's say, an
equal amount of reads and writes in your
application,
um then
and if you had a had a chain
replication, then this head node is
still going to get slammed, right?
Because
it, let's say, writes um
are um let's say writes take about four
times as long as reads,
um then then this process is still going
to have a lot more work to do than this
process.
Um in terms of responding to the client.
Um now,
if you had a different mix, if you had a
lot more reads than writes,
uh then it might actually make sense.
And so, next time we'll look at some
figures from the chain replication paper
that help illustrate
under what circumstances it makes sense
to do chain replication.
All right, we're out of time for today.
See you next time.